[Musik]
hey liebe wir machen heute mal ein brot
rezept denn ich habe auf meinen kalender
gesehen und bald ist der welttag des
brotes nämlich am 16 oktober und dafür
habe ich mir gedacht da ist jetzt auch
gar kein richtiges brot rezept auch
meinem kanal gibt überlege ich mir jetzt
für das erste brot rezept überhaupt mal
etwas richtig cooles wir machen nämlich
ein teil und erhalten zwei verschiedene
brote einmal ein brot und einmal einen
kartoffelbrot und hier habe ich die
zutaten bereit stehen die wir benötigen
das ist einmal das weizenmehl das
klassische denn einmal roggenmehl und
sonnenblumenöl hier habe ich kartoffeln
die sind festkochend außerdem möhren die
habe ich noch lauwarmes wasser zucker
salz und frische hefe bevor ich den teig
kneten kümmere ich mich zuallererst mit
kartoffeln denn die müssten wir gar und
damit wir später die schale besser
abkriegen habe ich einen kleinen tipp
für euch jetzt einfach ganz leicht an
der schale einmal um die kartoffel herum
mit einem messer und dann gibt er sie in
kochendes wasser
[Musik]
die kartoffeln nach dem garvorgang ganz
einfach schälen und reiben
das habe ich hier schon erledigt und
jetzt nehmen wir uns die möhren vor und
die werden auch geschält und gerieben
local communities wasser die komme ich
ins wasser guter einwand also schon
überlegt die dicken ja die ist es muss
man da wirklich so sagen die hier müssen
nicht vorher gegart werden da reicht
wenn sie ganz einfach roh verwendet
[Musik]
und jetzt bereiten wir auch schon den
teig so dafür habe ich jetzt hier eine
kleine schüssel und gebe da ein teil des
wassers hinzu achtet bitte darauf dass
das wasser lauwarm ist so um die 38 grad
dann ist es perfekt da lasse ich die
hefe rein bröseln gibt den zucker dazu
und das es zugedeckt ca 5 minuten stehen
[Musik]
die hilfe konnte jetzt fünf minuten lang
arbeiten und gäbe es jetzt auch nur ganz
kurz an die seite ich habe hier in
meiner großen schüssel meinen weizenmehl
allerdings ist es ganz wichtig ihr leben
gibt die ein teil des weißen jetzt erst
mal zur seite
das erkläre ich euch gleich ganz in ruhe
weil unser gemüse also die möhren und
die kartoffeln die enthalten ja auch
wasser und wir kompensieren das gleich
mit dem meer
ich gebe etwas roggenmehl mit zum
weizenmehl da kann auch schon das salz
mit hinzu und das roggenmehl verwende
ich deshalb dann habt ihr nämlich so
eine schöne rustikale eigenschaft und
das schmeckt richtig lecker und jetzt
fahre ich das alles mit den händen und
gibt die hefe und das öl auch noch mit
dazu
[Musik]
das restliche wasser auch mit hinzugeben
und da hilft euch wenn das auch lauwarm
ist
[Musik]
ihr wisst ja dass ich meine hilfe teig
immer ganz gerne mit den händen kneten
und zwar auf der arbeitsfläche hier in
dem fall insgesamt acht bis zehn minuten
dann verbindet sich alles schön und wir
können fortfahren und zudem gemüse noch
mal ganz kurz ein kleines statement ihr
wisst ja dass ich immer sehr auf
bioqualität achte und früher ist man
halt immer in den bioladen gegangen um
besonders gute bio qualität zu erhalten
und jetzt gibt es eben auch bei kaufland
da gibt es nämlich gemüse in demeter
qualität und die meter ist der höchste
anspruch an bio qualität und ich finde
es eben persönlich auch toll das ist das
bei kaufland gibt und man nicht dafür
extra verschiedene anlaufstellen hat und
was ich auch dazu sagen ist dann haben
sie nicht uns gerade unterhalten
es ist auch so ein bisschen trend
geworden darauf zu achten und das finde
ich persönlich richtig richtig cool und
wir können es ja auch fortfahren mit dem
teig ich hab den aids hier ordentlich
geknetet und wird jetzt mit meiner teig
karte einmal in der mitte durch teilen
dann gebe ich die eine hälfte die möhren
und in die andere hälfte die kartoffeln
[Musik]
so und jetzt merkt ihr dass der teig
wieder anfängt ein bisschen zu kleben
das ist ganz normal denn auch in den
kartoffeln ist ja ein bisschen
feuchtigkeit enthalten und daher
arbeiten wir dagegen mit ein bisschen
weizenmehl also einfach vorsichtig
einarbeiten
[Musik]
sobald dann die kartoffeln verarbeitet
sind und ihr zufrieden seid mit der
konsistenz eures teig für sollte wie
gesagt nicht zu hart und nicht zu
klebrig sein
ganz einfach den teig zu einer kugel
formt und entweder in einem der körbchen
geben mit ganz viel mehr ausströmt oder
falls ihr das nicht da hab dann nimmt er
einfach eine schüssel wichtig ist halt
wirklich dass sie ganz viele mehr daran
gibt damit er später auch ganz einfach
stürzen könnt und danach machen wir das
gleiche auch mit den möhren
[Musik]
mein möhren brotteig ist jetzt auch
fertig das gibt's jetzt einmal umgedreht
in mein anderes geld köpfchen
wie gesagt ihr könnt ihr auch gerne eine
schüssel verwenden falls jetzt kein geld
köpfchen da habt wichtig ist dass wir
das ganze jetzt einmal zugedeckt 60
minuten ruhen lassen und die tiger sind
wunderbar aufgegangen so sind genau
perfekt jetzt habe ich jemanden
backblech bereit ein back-up hier oben
drauf und jetzt stürzen wenn die ganz
einfach und wenn ihr das gut vorher mit
mehl bestäubt habe die form dann geht es
auch wie von alleine raus da brauchte
ich gar keine sorgen machen
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt noch mal ein bug pinsel
und dem das überschüssige mail weg das
kann jetzt nicht ganz weg vom teig das
ist auch gar kein problem
wir geben da jetzt sowieso noch ein
bisschen was darüber das ist ganz
normales leitungswasser und pinseln
jetzt die oberfläche damit das bewegt
einfach dass wir später eine schöne
knusprige kruste haben und noch ein
trick den zeigen sich aber gleich erst
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die oberfläche mit
leitungswasser benetzt habt gebe ich
euch auch den top tipp für richtig
knuspriges brot ihr gebt einfach eine
feuerfeste schale zb eine auflaufform
mit wasser in den ofen boden und ihr
habt so eine knusprige außenhülle und im
innern ist es total weich aber das
endergebnis seht ja gleich nach dem
backen
ich gebe jetzt die brote bei 225 grad
ober unterhitze für 35 bis 40 minuten in
den backofen wobei mein kartoffelbrot
glaube ich etwas länger braucht dem gebe
ich 40 minuten und das obwohl ich nach
35 minuten aus dem ofen bis gleich
[Musik]
und ihr seht ihr wie einfach es ist brot
selber zu backen und bei diesem rezept
habt ihr sogar 21 also direkt zwei
verschiedene brote und ist euch
aufgefallen dass das murren brot auch
eine ganz andere farbe hat durch die
möhren ich finde super spannend und
falls ihr jetzt lust drauf habt
unbedingt in die infobox schauen da
stehen alle genauen mengenangaben und
dann wünsche ich euch ganz viel freude
beim nachbacken also ich persönlich mag
auf meinem bruder am liebsten einfach
nur ein bisschen butter weil wenn das
brot selbst gemacht ist dann hat das
schon den ganzen geschmack dann braucht
es eigentlich gar nicht viel mehr was
mit ihr am liebsten auf euren brot
schreibt es mir in die kommentare
haben sie hat ein favorit frischkäse
frischkäse mit lauchzwiebeln ich hab
hunger
ok ich lasse euch jetzt und wünsche euch
noch einen wunderschönen tag und bis zum
nächsten mal auf die skizzen tschüss
[Musik]